[Music]
[Applause]
Josh Schrock covers the Bears for NBC
Sports Chicago
he joins us now boy you had a day
yesterday there Josh when did you know
that it was a mess when you showed up at
the facility
uh I'd say about
90 seconds after Justin Fields took the
podium and it was clear that he had a
lot of things on his mind and a lot of
things to say and uh things just
snowballed from there they just they
just kept going until about seven
o'clock at night so it was a bizarre and
very weird day at house Hall and one
that will probably Define this team but
I wonder about the tweet that was sent
out and it stopped with just he blames
coaching and then we didn't add anything
else to that tweet so we had to wait to
really find out the context of that if
he you flip it around where he takes
blame and then he mentions the code like
it just felt like if he handled it
differently then this isn't a big deal
do you agree
I I agree I think Justin is a very smart
kid and I think he clearly went to the
podium yesterday with an idea of what
was being said about him and how things
are going and he wanted to get out in
front of some of the issues and he
starts with it could be coaching and
then proceeds to say it's also on me but
look he was very critical of the staff
and I think he meant what he said he was
direct confident he didn't torch them
and I think he went to the practice
field and then got off and saw everyone
just running with the one thing and was
like wow okay I need to backtrack
because it's a quarterback's unwritten
law that I don't just come out and blast
everyone so he wants to make it clear
that he does blame himself but
everything he said
he meant
okay
but if you look at this situation how do
you troubleshoot this if you're the
Bears front office coaching staff and
Justin fields
well I think they could have helped
themselves a lot if they had
understood their personnel better like a
job of a good coordinator and a good
coach is to know your players strengths
and to game plan around what they do
best not game plan around what you want
to do and anyone who's watched the Bears
through the first two games can tell you
that's not the offense they should be
running that's not the offense that made
Justin special last year uh so that's
where they could have started that was
about two months ago but as of now they
need they need to scrap everything they
need to scrap the Aaron rodgers-esque
offense that Luke getsy wants to run and
they need to listen to what Justin's
saying and just do what he does best
four quarterback design runs in two
games is not nearly enough they've
really cobwebbed the vertical passing
game except the two drives they scored
against Tampa they need to do what this
offense was built to do they told us
it's built around Mobility it's built
around vertical passing and then they
just completely disregarded all of that
for the first two weeks and have made
Justin think too much and play pretty
poorly and he owns some of that blame
but they need to scrap everything they
need to scrap the game plan and they
need to do what makes him comfortable
because that's the only way they're
going to win
but the big question is still going to
be can he beat you from the pocket right
when it's all said and done he was a
curiosity it was fun to watch they don't
win but are are you okay with that if
you're a Chicago Bear fan would you
rather just be entertaining and maybe
you're not going to win games or can you
try to
are they trying to make him something
that he's not therefore you're going to
lose games either way
Justin says they're not I think what he
was getting at yesterday was what he's
good at and what they want him to do do
not align at the moment and they need to
find a way to mesh the two he's he's not
trying to say I don't want to play from
the pocket but what he's saying is I
don't want to just stand there like
they're telling me to do and go one two
three pause wait make sure it's good and
then get out I need to still play free
and right now he's thinking way too much
because he wants to do everything that
they tell him to do by to a T and that's
just not that's not going to work at
this level Dan like it's clear against
the bucks he was freezing his brain was
locking up and it led to a lot of
mistakes he missed open receivers he
admitted the strip sack was that was
what happened right he's like I would
have been out of there last year but I'm
just trying to do what they're telling
me so they need to figure out a way to
get him to play from the pocket but also
utilize that athleticism and they need
to roll the pocket they need to not make
it so hey everything is just straight
drop back behind a bad offensive line
and try to make it work
yeah because there were a couple of
reads against Tampa Bay where you're
going I got two guys open yeah and he
was freezing yep
um
but he might just be one he might be
like Cam Newton that you just say look
do it how you need to do it for as long
as you can do it and then we saw what
happened cam fell off a cliff he
couldn't play anymore
um he got him to a Super Bowl but but I
you know he's been and I was just
talking to Andy Staples who covers
college football and he said you know
there were questions about Justin Fields
when he was in college at Ohio State
that you didn't have to do much because
your receivers are so good Ryan Day
offensive minded head coach and you know
you're not reading as much now in the
NFL you do have to go through your
progressions or at least most of the
elite quarterbacks and then you have
Kansas City coming up this weekend it
just feels like this is Justin Fields is
going to put on the cape and go out
there and try to be Justin fields of
last year
yeah and honestly at this point Dan the
offensive line is so banged up and
they're making so many mental mistakes
offensively the receivers are running
the wrong routes they're standing next
to each other the only way this is gonna
even have a chance to be successful on
Sunday against the team that's much more
talented than they are both sides the
ball is for Justin to just be Superman
like he was last year and try to will
them to 30 points
um I think your point about you know Cam
Newton yeah that might end up being what
Justin is I think he's been put in a
horrible spot to start his career he's
had no continuity he's had you know Matt
Nagy now Lou getsy and no one's
engineered anything around him you think
about what Greg Mo Greg Roman did with
Lamar Jackson right where it was like
okay let's just let's just package what
you do well will make you successful you
win an MVP and now Todd Monk Is building
on that they've gotten him weapons and
he was able to progress as a quarterback
Justin's not had any of that and I mean
honestly things are things are spiraling
right now for the Bears and like I said
it kind of reeks of Naggy trubisky 2.0
right where Mitch got binged and and
then he came out and started talking
freely about the scheme issues and how
he was uncomfortable and to Justin's
credit he knows this is this is his
career and he has to get out in front of
us and say hey yeah I'm playing bad part
of it's on me part of it's because I'm
just doing what I'm told and it needs to
change and he had all of this unfolding
and then your defensive coordinator
resigns yesterday do we have any more
information on why he decided to step
away
for his health and to be with his family
the situation remains incredibly murky
uh it was even murkier yesterday when
the Bears released a one-line statement
that said he resigned Dan I mean you
know even when people fire Executives or
coaches it's always we thank you for
your service we appreciate the time
you'll be a you know a bear for life it
was none of that it was hey he's gone so
something else is going on I think of
them health because it was just Health
and Family they would have wished him
well and said you know he can come back
anytime if he wants and that's clearly
not the case
they've already taken him off the
website yep I mean they're they're
scrubbing any any remnants of of him
distancing themselves
and just the rumors that are out there
yeah I mean that's the world the only
reason we know he resigned is because of
those rumors and social media because
otherwise the Bears were really content
on keeping it hey we don't have an
update he's not here for now
great appearance Josh thanks for joining
us uh have fun today I always do Dan
thanks for having me thank you Josh
Schrock Bears Insider NBC Sports Chicago